Tequila heated to 800 degrees celsius can
be made into diamonds.
The snow at the South Pole reflects sound
so well you can hear people talking a mile
away.
Nachos were invented by a man named Nacho.
Human teeth evolved from fish scales.
'Last shake o' the bag' was Victorian slang
for 'youngest child'.
Salamanders can hear with their lungs.
In 1989, a Russian psychic was run over by
a train and killed while attempting to prove
he could stop one using the power of his mind.
Astronaut Harrison Schmitt is allergic to
the Moon.
All the chickens' eggs produced in the world
each year would make an omelette the size
of Northern Ireland.
When neuroscientist James Fallon studied the
brain scans of murderers using his own scan
as a control, he discovered he was a psychopath.
There are more than 1,000 species of banana
and we eat only one of them.
John F. Kennedy's brain was removed during
his autopsy and is still missing.
For 500 years from the 13th century, 70% of
Englishmen were called Robert, John, Thomas,
Richard or William.
2.8 million American dogs are on antidepressants.
Traffic lights were introduced 18 years before
the car was invented.
80% of people who are struck by lightning
survive.